ces rues en pente sa lumière mystérieuse
qui a inspiré les plus grands
réalisateurs ces maisons blanches et ses
fameux tramways
aidé par sa beauté naturelle et sa météo
clémente San Francisco a toujours été
capable d'attirer les visionnaires et
l'innovation de la contre-culture
jusqu'au grandes entreprises de la
Silicon Valley mais le vin est-il en
train de tourner
ce spécialiste des technologies
Washington pose croit que les mises à
pied massive chez Twitter et Facebook
deux icônes fortement touchés par
l'inflation et les ralentissements
économiques ne sont peut-être que le
commencement
des joueurs risquent de tomber lors des
prochains mois ce qui ne ferait pas ce
programmeur du Québec qui travaille pour
le site redit donc vous avez pas de part
de perdre votre emploi actuellement ça
pourrait arriver en ce moment
pour se dirigeante québécois se présente
en Californie depuis 8 ans le
ralentissement est inévitable on parle
de deux gens comme vous et moi qui
perdent leur emploi avec des familles et
tout pas facile mais malheureusement les
les marchés ont changé et les compagnies
doivent s'adapter
mais la crise dans les techno n'est pas
le seul problème la taxation élevée les
inégalités sociales et les loyers
inabordables on fait baisser les
investissements étrangers à leur plus
bas niveau leur passé mais
you can Ford home
le coût de la vie est un frein quoi
aussi Gabriel Dion un autre québécois
qui s'est établi dans la région c'est
très très dispendieux il se dernier qui
aide les entreprises dans leur projet
d'expansion croient que la ville
conserve une forte attractivité le
talent va être si les personnes
hautement qualifiées qui sont à la
recherche de d'un dépassement
professionnel je crois que c'est un
autre type qui vient et San Francisco va
renaître si on veut dans les années
futures
après des années d'hyper croissance San
Francisco doit maintenant affronter des
vents contraires mais plusieurs ici
espèrent que la crise sera passagère et
que la ville a suffisamment d'atouts
pour demeurer la Mecque la technologie
mondiale ici Olivier Bourque
Radio-Canada SAN